So, I want to pick up in August the 16th, 1923. There are some really wonderful messages
coming now. The reason why Jesus wants his will to be done and the glory that he receives
from it, very important. So, Louisa said, "I was thinking to myself, 'Why does blessed
Jesus have so much interest and want and love so much that his will be done? What glory
can he receive from a poor wretched creatures surrendering her will in his most high, most
holy and most lovable will?" Now, that is a very important question that when you go
to conferences or give classes, people will ask you, "How can I make that kind of an
impression on God?" Okay, so it's a very important question. So, while I was thinking
about this, my lovable Jesus with unspeakable tenderness and sweetness told me, "My daughter,
do you want to know? Because my love, that should be a capital L, my supreme goodness
is so great that every time the soul, I'm going to say soul instead of creature, does
my will and operates it because I want it is the bit you underline. Not because we want
it, it's because he wants it. I give her of my own. That means that he gives us of the
divine. And in order to always give her of my own, I want her to do my will. Now, to
do my will, the way it is expressed here by the translations, it means to live in the
divine will. Therefore, the whole reason, the interest for which I want her to do my
will is to find occasions and means to be able to always give. So, I want to give you
one of the great statements made about love, and I can't remember who made it. Love lives
by giving, giving all. It's one of the saints. Love lives by giving, giving all. And that's
what you hear Jesus saying here, that he wants us to surrender to his will so that we give
him an opportunity to be able to give on a divine level to us. Okay. So, it is my love
that wants, does not want to be still. It wants to run, to fly towards the creature.
But to do what it is to give, there's the give, give, give all the time, notice it. And
by doing my will, she comes closer to me and I to her. And I give and she takes, we're
on the receiving end all the time. On the other hand, if she does not operate in order
to do my will, she places herself in due distance from me. Now, notice the decision is
ours, whether we surrender or whether we stay at a distance. Rendering herself as though
foreign to me. And therefore, she cannot take what I may want to give her. Now, why he will
he will tell us in the messages coming up. The reason why it would be foreign is that
his divine will fills everything and fills the whole earth. So, if we've distanced ourselves
from that, it's like to use the language of some of the programs. Now, we're extraterrestrials.
We put ourselves at a distance from the divine will, which is in everything and running everything.
Okay. And therefore, she cannot take what I want to give her. That's very interesting,
isn't it? So, if you have a person in the room who is blind and deaf and you hand out
a bag of sweets, they can't see them and they can't hear you saying it. So, they cannot
receive what you're offering. So, that's really saying that we put ourselves in the
position of not being able to receive by putting ourselves in the position of not surrendering
our will. It's very logical what we're going to be reading now. And if I wanted to give
her of my own, that is of the divine, it would be noxious and indigestible for her because
her palate unrefined and contaminated by the human will would not allow her to enjoy or
to appreciate the divine gifts. That's like saying, I go to Japan. I can't eat the food.
My palate cannot deal with this. My digestive system can't deal with this. And so, I'm in
trouble by the fact that I can't deal with it. And that's what he's saying here that
people who are committed to their own will, what did I do with that? Never mind. People
who are committed to their own will cannot actually receive what he wants to give us
on the divine level. So, therefore, my whole interest is because I want to always give
her of my own. Now, he wants to give divine gifts, carisms and graces. I'm going to have
to get a drink. A divine gifts, carisms and graces. And the person doing self-worth is
not in that way of being able to receive. Divine gifts that can receive human love.
Okay. So, that's the giving end of it. Now, the next bit is about his glory. As from
my glory, he said, "It is the same glory that I received through the works of the creature
who does my will. It is a glory which descends from heaven and rises again straight back
to the foot of my throne, multiplied by the divine will exercised by that soul." Okay.
So, what gives him glory is that what he has given to us is received, multiplied and sent
back to him. In other words, the circuit of love is complete. The circuit of love is not
complete in the one who does their own will. Nothing goes back to the Lord. On the other
hand, the glory which those who do not do my will may give me, if there is any at all,
is a glory foreign to me because it's not his own, which many times reaches the point
of giving me nausea. You can't take it. Now, you have all the references for all of that,
for the past 16 volumes, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God and
all the rest of it. Okay. So, more so, since when the creature operates in order to do
my will, by giving her of my own, that is of the divine, together with that work, I place,
now this is infusing into us. Notice, I said infusing. I didn't say infusing. Infusing.
It's put into you from outside. I place my sanctity, my power, my wisdom, the beauty
of my works and incalculable of infinite value. So, here he says, "I give you a gift of absolutely
immeasurable value when you actually just open up to the divine will because he gives
us his sanctity." Now, his sanctity is a divine sanctity. You're not talking about human
stuff. You're talking about divine power. You're talking about divine wisdom. You're
talking about the beauty of divine works. That's why they're of infinite value. I could say
that those are fruits of my lands, works of my celestial kingdom, the glory of my family
and of my legitimate children. Now, you know that the legitimate children are the children
of the divine will. So, that's Romans 8, 19. That the whole of creation is waiting for
these children. So, how could they not be pleasing to me? He said, "How could I not feel the enrapturing
power of my supreme volition in that work of the creature who only operates to do my will?"
Now, put a little ring around only because our problem is that you may do it and then
you may do other things besides. And this is moving entirely towards complete 100% giving.
So, if all knew the good of the divine will, that's the it, they would not let themselves
be deceived. Look at the word by their own wills. Now, deceived is that 99.9% of humanity
is deceived, thinking that what they're doing of their own will is the good thing, is the
best thing and so on. Okay. So, following on to this in August the 20th, 1923, we have
a very, very important message on sanctity in the divine will. Put a VIP on it. Okay.
So, Louisa said, "I was thinking to myself, my good Jesus says many admirable things about
his will and how there is nothing greater, higher, holier than the soul whom he calls
to live in his volition." It's a wonderful definition there. Okay. "If it were so,"
she said, "who knows how many admirable things I should be doing, how many sensational things
almost externally." Now, I don't very much if that idea came from Louisa herself. I would
think it came from the priest saying to her, "If you're saying that this is the greatest
holiness and the most incredible things, well, why are there no external works?" And
it's a very, this is a very important answer to questions people will ask you. Okay. So,
it's the external things. Yet she says, Louisa says, "There's nothing charming or striking.
On the contrary, I feel I'm the most abject and insignificant person who does nothing,
good, sorry. While the saints, how much good do they not do, sensational things and miracles?"
And yet, he says, that is Jesus says, that the living in his will leaves all the saints
behind. Now, it's a very important question and the answer is supremely important and
you're going to need this in teaching others. There's wonderful answers here for people
teaching. Now, while these and other thoughts were passing through my mind, my Jesus moved
in my interior, so she's going to get infused knowledge. And with his usual light, that's
the infused knowledge, he told me, my daughter, when a sanctity is individual for a time and
for a particular place, it has more of external prejudice. Now, you know that when you speak
about saints, we say rose of Lima, we say, Padre Pio of Petrolcina, we say Bernadette
of Lords. Now, notice all the time I've connected it with a place. Now, that's the way the church
remembers saints. And Jesus says, if it's individual for a time and a place, there's
more external prejudice. In order to attract those individuals, those places and those
times, to be able to receive the grace and the good that that sanctity actually contains.
So on the other hand, the sanctity of living in my will is not an individual sanctity.
This is very important. It's not a devotion. It's not anything to do with individual sanctity.
It's not a sign to doing good to certain places or to certain people at certain times. Rather,
it is a sanctity which must do good to all in all times and in all places. You see, it's
in the divine will and the divine will is in everything and there's no time in the divine
will. It's a sanctity which remains eclipsed in the eternal sun of my will, which invading
all that means from Adam to Zachary is light without speech, fire without wood, without
clamor and without smoke. But in spite of this, it does not cease to be the most majestic,
the most beautiful, the most fertile. It's light is more pure. It's heat is more intense.
The true image of this divine sanctity is the sun which illuminates our horizon. That's
very interesting. So he's saying here that the image of this divine sanctity is the sun.
He speaks of himself having the sun as an image and he's going to tell us very soon
that the sun is also an image of the sanctity of our blessed mother. And the reason is that
it's doing good to all. It's giving light and help and everything to all and yet it remains
completely silent in the background. Everybody sees it. Everybody benefits from it and everybody
selects it. And then he's going to say that as we go on and he's going to say only if
I take the sun away will they notice that they need it. In other words, it's so presumed
and he says that the divine will sanctity is like that. It's in the background doing
enormous work, but not in a way that anybody can interfere with, which I think is terribly
important. You see, if you have the person out there doing miracles, you can kill them
off and the miracles stop you. Okay. So the light is more pure. The heat is more intense.
The true image of it is the sun which illuminates our horizon. It illuminates all but without
clamor. It is light, but it has no speech. It says nothing to anyone. The good it does,
the seeds it fertilizes, the life it gives to plants and how it purifies the polluted
air with its heat and destroys what can be harmful to humanity. And yet it's so silent.
Now, you see, you're getting an image of this spirituality. It's so silent that even though
they have it with them, they pay no attention to it. Okay. But in spite of this, it does
not cease to be majestic and beautiful and to continue to give good to all. And if the
sun were missing, everyone would mourn for it because the greatest miracle of fecundity
or fertility and preservation of all nature would be missing. In other words, life would
actually stop on planet earth without it. Now, that's what he's comparing divine will
sanctity to. You need to just think that one through. That's what he's comparing it to.
And it is that important. So I want to give you a little heading for the next paragraph,
God's Army. And you're going to need this in preparation for Dromantine. There's an
awful lot of answers for Dromantine in what I was studying today. The sanctity of living
in my will is more than the sun. The soul who is upright and fully ordered in my will
is more than an army in battle array. Now, that is Song of Songs 610. Who is this coming
off in the desert like an army in battle array? Her intelligence is ordered and bound to the
eternal intelligence. Her heartbeats, affections, desires are ordered with the eternal bonds.
And therefore her thoughts, her will, and the whole of her interior are armies of messengers
which come from her and fill heaven and earth. Okay. So I want to give you John 151, the ladder
that connects heaven and earth and all the commerce that's going up and down through
that ladder. They are speaking voices. They are weapons which defend and first of all,
and their God. I want to give you two Corinthians 4, 10 for that. But this army is different
to the armies of earth because it's silent. They bring good to all. They are true celestial
and divine militia which the supreme majesty keeps all ordered within himself ever ready
for all of his commands. So there's an army ready to do the commands of the army in chief.
Now, a century ago, Mactimilian Colby set up the militia of Mary Immaculate and that
everybody was to be completely committed to her so that she could carry out her battles
and somebody's phone. And so here's the Lord is calling the people living in the divine
will a divine militia. So he's calling us a divine militia. Therefore, if the language
of army or militia is used, it means there is a task to be accomplished. And the task
can only be accomplished with the guidance of the supreme commander. And only if the
will of the supreme commander is carried out will the job be done. So it's a very interesting
thing. So what you're looking at here is the absolute obedience to the divine will.
So in the next paragraph, we have the Blessed Virgin Mary as the true exemplar of this sanctity
in the divine will. So and then there is the example of my mother. She's the true sanctity,
a true sanctity of living in my will. Her interior was all eclipsed in the eternal
sun of the supreme volition. Having to be the queen of the sanctity of the saints, having
to be the mother and bearer of my life to all and therefore of all goods, she remained
as though hidden within all. Now notice the within. This is very interesting because this
sanctity means that the divine will is in everybody and is in everything you enter into
the divine will and you are present in everyone and in everything. So you are praying from
within the person. It's absolutely an astonishing thing. But the power of that is extraordinary.
So she was hidden within all, bringing good without making herself recognized. Look at
that. The emphasis that Jesus is giving in this message is that this sanctity works best
when it's hidden. More than the silent sun, she would bring light without speech, fire
without clamor, good without exposing herself. And I have put song of songs for 15 there.
Song of songs for 15. There was no good which would not come from her. And that's where
her final title of Mediatrix of all graces is going to come from. Everything is to come
from her. Why is it to come from her? Because she's in the divine will and everything comes
from the divine will. There are other ways of talking about it as well, of course. There
was no miracle which would not spring from her because the divine will had complete dominion.
By living in my will, she lived hidden within all. And therefore she's praying inside of
me for me. It's not fantastic. And when you're praying for your family in the divine will,
you're praying inside of them as well. It's not wonderful. That's why I have this great
peace about bride because every night I pray in the divine will for the dying. So that
the Lord will give them absolutely everything they need in the divine will. So I know she
had it. And the lily she gave me is the proof. Those of you who haven't seen the lily, she
gave me a gift of a lily in the garden. So there was no miracle that wouldn't spring
from her from our blessed mother because the divine will was operating within her. By living
in my will, she lived hidden within all and she was and is the origin of the goods of
all. You can't improve on that statement, can you? She was so enraptured in God, so
fixed and ordered in the divine will that her whole interior swam in the sea of the eternal
volition. Now you'll notice if you go back one paragraph to God's army and the Lord
speaks about us as being fully ordered in the divine will. Now the struggle we have in
getting to that is that everything inside of us, our thoughts, our words, our actions,
our motivations, our desires, everything has to actually be reordered around the divine
will. Whereas we started off with it being ordered around my will. Do you know what I
mean? And so the struggle we have to get into this place is that reordering. Okay? And here
you're told about blessed mother that everything was ordered in the divine will. And she was
so enraptured in God, so fixed. Notice the so that her whole interior swam in the sea
of the eternal volition. She was aware of the whole interior of all creatures. Now that
has to be an absolutely superlative project. Just take the fact that there are there are
only approximately 7.5 billion on the planet today. That's not taking the numbers that
have gone in the past and the numbers that will be that she is aware of the interior
of everybody. Okay? And she would place her own wonderful interior in order to reorder
them before God. So what was she doing? Although silent years in Nazareth, she was doing this.
It was precisely the interior of man more than the outside that was in greater need of being
redone and reordered because the kingdom of God is within the body is only the case that's
carrying this extraordinary treasure. And so having to do the greater, it seemed that
she would leave the lesser. Now what's the lesser? The lesser is the projities and the
miracles and the preaching before millions and getting famous on the earth and all the
rest with others do. So he said that's the lesser because the divine will is the source
of that preaching. The source of that success is the foot of the missionary, the voice of
the preacher and so on and so on. So she would leave out the lesser while she was the origin
of both because you had that at the beginning in the paragraph talking about the sanctity
of the divine will that the divine will is light without speech, fire without wood and
without clamor without smoke. We've just read that. Okay? So the divine will is the origin
of both the external and the internal good that the saints do. Yet on the outside it seemed
that she would not do great and sensational works. She was known in the village of Nazareth
as being a very nice lady and she collected her water like everybody else and did her
messages like everybody else. It didn't appear that there was. Well, yeah, I think you'd
have to be blind not to notice the sanctity that was there, but it didn't appear there
was anything sensational. So more than the sun she would pass unobserved and hidden in
the cloud of light of the divine will. So I want to give you song of songs for 12 for
that. I've already given you 415. So much so that the very saints have given of themselves
doing apparently more sensational things than my mother did. Yet what are the greatest
saints in comparison with her? They're just little stars. That's Daniel 12, 3. Stars are
symbols of the people of God. They're little stars by comparison with the sun. And if they
are illuminated, it's because of the sun. But even though she did not do sensational things,
she did not cease to be also visibly. That's what I'm saying. You'd have to be blind not
to notice the sanctity. Also visibly majestic and beautiful, just barely hovering over the
earth. I just love that expression. All intent on that eternal will with great love and violence,
as Matthew 1112, the kingdom of God suffers violence and the violence taken by force.
That means you've got to fight for the kingdom of God as we all know. You've got to fight
every inch of the way to get every part of you reordered in the divine will. And it is
a battle. If it isn't a battle for you, talk to me for God's sake. Because it's the battle
for the rest of us. And with great love and violence, she charmed and enraptured in order
to transport the divine will from heaven to earth. And which the human family had so brutally
exiled even into the Empyrean heaven. I looked up the dictionary and they don't have Empyrean
anymore. So it means God's actual home. Because it's not paradise. It's not the other levels.
You know, St. Paul said he was raised up to the seventh heaven or something. And she,
with all of her interior ordered in the divine will, would give no time to time. I haven't
come across that expression before. It's not fascinating. We would say she gave no time
to earth. She gave no time to time. She gave all her time to eternity. So that's just
a very extraordinary expression. I just want to point out to you. She would give no time
to time. I just haven't met that before. Whether she would think Palpatate, breathe,
or anything else she would do. These were all charming bonds in order to draw the eternal
word upon the earth. And in fact, she did win. And she performed the greatest miracle,
of course, which is to let the incarnation happen. It's not a fantastic description.
And then he says, "This is your task, my daughter." And this is addressed to Louisa
because her job is to open the kingdom of the divine will. It is to charm me and to bind
me so much with your interior all reordered in the sublime volition as to transport the
divine will from heaven to earth. That it may be known and have life on the earth as
it does in heaven. That's the fulfillment on the Our Father. Have no concern about anything
else. One who must do the greater has no need of the lesser. What are the lesser? All the
external things. On the contrary, the field is given to others so that they may do the
minor part in order to give work to all. I love that. Everybody needs a job to do. So
you give the minor soldiers in the army and then the officers do different things, then
the general does different things altogether. I know what is needed, he said, the time,
the place, and the people. Oh, we'd need to remember that all the time, wouldn't we?
And I have to make known my greatest works also with external prodigies because he doesn't
stop working miracles. As for you, continue always your flight in my divine will. There's
the eagle must fly high all the time. Filling heaven and earth, charming me so much that
I may not be able to resist performing the greatest miracle, which is that that my will
should reign in the midst of creatures, which of course will be the triumph of the Sacred
Heart. So August the 28th is about possession of God. Give yourself a title for that. This
is very important. One of the things that I will speak about in Dromantine is the fact
that I have a problem with Louisa's writings. And the problem is that in Volume 1, Louisa
has three spiritual marriages and the 35 volumes sit on that relationship. And even with these
three spiritual marriages, and she's the only saint I know who's had three, the 35 volumes
sit on that and yet she had to go through extraordinary purification. And the problem
with us is I don't know anyone who's had three spiritual marriages. Do you? Two spiritual
marriages? No. One spiritual marriage? Don't put your hands up. So we're in a different
field altogether. We're just not classified in the same field. And if we start getting
this clearer in our heads, we will apply this material better to ourselves, I think, because
the Lord wants me to clarify, clarify, clarify, so that we actually know where we're coming
from, where we are, where we're going, and that we know how to apply this material. Is
that okay? So this is why he speaks about possession of the divine will in August 28th
because it presumes union with God. You can't be out of union with God and have possession
of God. That's a contradiction in terms. Okay? So August 28th here is a big correction
for anybody who thinks they're flying high in the divine will. I was feeling highly afflicted,
Louisa said, because of the privation of my sweet Jesus. As much as I called him and prayed
him, he would not gain to return to his little exiled one down here. How hard is my exile?
My poor heart was agonizing because of the pain of it for the one because of the pain
it felt for the one who forms its life and is far away from me. Now she says that the
Lord is far away from her and the divine will is lodged inside of her. Now, so her problem
is she wants to see him externally outside of herself. That's her problem. But while
I was longing for his return, the confessor came and at that precise moment after I had
waited for so long, Jesus moved in my interior just as the confessor came. So it's not convenient.
So watch her reacting. She's been looking for him all the time and then he comes when it's
not convenient. I think it's fantastic. He moved in my interior, squeezing my heart tightly
and making himself seen. And so Louisa said, "My Jesus, why couldn't you come before?"
It's not fantastic. Now I must obey. If it pleases you, you will come when I receive
you in Holy Communion. And with him we will be alone again and will be free together.
And Jesus with a dignified and indifferent appearance. In other words, you don't tick
God off. And you don't tell him it's inconvenient. Try the incarnation. It was before Blessed
Mother went through the marriage ceremony. Was it inconvenient? St. Elizabeth, who gave
birth to John the Baptist, was it inconvenient? She was too old. Try Abraham's wife Sarah,
was it inconvenient? Did they have to agree and cooperate? So Louisa's intimacy with him
in being able to tick him off like this is fascinating, but I like his reaction with
dignified and indifferent tone. My daughter, do you want me to destroy the order of my
wisdom and to take away the authority I gave to my church? In other words, don't dictate
to God. We do it very well. We like telling God what to do. I remember reading in some
book that everybody knows how to pope, except the pope. And everybody knows how to run a
government, except the people who are actually elected, because everybody else knows what
they should be doing. And if you're watching a match on the television, you tell the players
where to put the ball from your superior position of not being involved. It's fascinating, isn't
it? So afterwards, Louisa said, she said to Jesus, but tell me my love, why don't you
come? He did come, you know? And you make me wait so much as to almost make me lose the
hope of your return. And because of the pain, my heart struggles between life and death.
And Jesus, all goodness, look at this, said my daughter, having placed in you the ownership
of my will, that is the possession of God. I want you not only to possess the divine will,
but to know how to keep it well, to cultivate it, to expand it, and also to multiply it.
You're not, you're not supposed to take a gift and do nothing with it. Do you remember
the story of the man with the one talent? And he gave it back and said, this is your talent.
And he was punished. Okay. So we have to be able to take ownership, keep it well, cultivate
it, expand it and multiply it. This is terribly important. Therefore, pains, mortifications,
vigilance, patience, and also my very privation serve to expand and to keep the boundaries
of my will in your soul. In other words, you need this pain in order to be able to stay
completely spiritual. We have this problem, don't we? That it's so easy to slip back
and to just relact into the human and relact into the ordinary. Okay. And it is not enough.
You need to put an envy on this one. It's not enough to possess one must know how to possess.
What good is it for a man to possess a land if he does not take care of sowing it, of cultivating
it, of keeping it, and then reap the fruits of his toils? If he does not work his field,
even though he possesses it, it can be said that he has nothing with which to satisfy
his hunger. So it's not possessing that renders man rich and happy, but knowing how to cultivate
well what he possesses. That paragraph, you must put a VIP on the whole thing. In other
words, if you don't use the gift, if you don't operate the kingdom, you lose it. And it's
the same way I learned how to play the piano when I was a child, but my parents were too
poor to have such a huge thing, and there wouldn't be room in the house for such a huge thing.
So what do you do? You forget. So it is with my graces, Jesus said, and with my gifts,
and especially my will, which I have placed in you as a queen. Now, I love the term queen
as distinct from king. It wants from you the food, the crafting of your pains and of your
acts, in everything it wants that your will fully submitted to it, would give it the honors
and the courtage that be fitted as queen. And in everything you do and suffer, the divine
will will have ready the food to feed your soul. And so you on one side and my will on
the other will expand the boundaries of my supreme will within you. Okay. I can't answer
the question, why is it not king? I'll have to find that out eventually. He says queen,
not king. Maybe it's king in heaven and queen on earth. I'm just not sure. So September
2nd and 1923 is about Louisa. Louisa offers the pain of humanity separated from God in
addition to the pain of the privation of Jesus. And then the nations are preparing for war.
I felt very embittered, she said, because of the privation of my adorable Jesus. More
so since making himself seen like a flash, he would draw me outside of myself. And while
he would escape like a flash, I would be forced to see tragic and gloomy things and rumors
of wars as if they wanted to involve Italy. Now, when she makes a comment like that, I
always laugh. He's trying to get her to look at the whole world, the whole global system.
And everything's fine, but most involve Italy. Do you know what I mean? And here, this is
a woman of great sanctity. The Lord is using her to bring the divine will on the earth.
And you still have these little foibles there. So have mercy on yourself, won't you? Have
mercy on yourself. So she said, I had to look at these gloomy scenes as if they wanted to
involve Italy. Leaders of governments approaching other leaders. Watch this now. This is prior
to the Second World War. And what did she see? Leaders of governments approaching other leaders
offering sums of money to make them fall into the net of war. So the Second World War was
very well organized. From the month of January of this year, that's 1923, when one day I
was in great suffering, Jesus had told me that he was making me suffer in order to give
light to the nations, which wanting to make war, wanted to drag others along, offering
great sums to draw them to themselves. Now we do know that there are people on the earth
who finance wars, both sides of it, because they're going to benefit. So you see the sheer
evil that war is even before they fire a shot. What pain it was for me to go outside of myself
to see people suffering, another war field being armed, and not to have my Jesus together
with me to say a word to him, the snatch from him, even at the cost of pain, mercy for unfortunate
humanity. Now she doesn't really look at the fact of what she said above, and that is that
the Lord made her suffer so that he could give light to the nations. That means that
he would actually give wisdom and understanding to try and stop the war. So I spent several
days in this state, she said, and my heart could take no more. I felt not only the pain
of being almost without Jesus, but another pain so hard that I myself was unable to manifest
it. And then he made himself seen for just a little clinging to my heart, seeking refuge
and rest, for he could take no more. And I classed unto myself, and I said to him, my
life, Jesus, tell me, where have I offended you that you do not come? What is this pain
on top of the pain of your privation that lacerates me and separates me from you? That
me, me should be small M's because it's Louisa. And Jesus all afflicted told me, my daughter,
have you perhaps placed in anything your will to offend me, that you fear that I have withdrawn
from you? And she said, no, my Jesus, I want to die rather than displease you. And he said,
well, then, a doffer who has always been with her father must be attentive on knowing the
secrets, the manners, the reasons for the way he deals with her. Okay? I have been with
you for so long. And you still do not know the reasons which force me to withdraw from
you. Beside that, I want to give you John 14 5. Have I been with you all this time? And
you still haven't understood? Because we were told many times in volumes one to five that
he withdrew in order to do the chastisements. But you have understood them, he said, and
also from the grave evils that you saw that I would come to you like a flash and drawing
you outside of myself, I would leave you alone wandering around the earth. How many tragic
things have you not seen? And on top of this, the great preparations for war which the nations
are making. Now watch this. This is 1923. Last year, that's 1922, France by moving against
Germany sounded the first bell. Italy by moving against Greece sounded the second bell of
war. Look at the way he's showing the thing is actually very well orchestrated. And then
another nation will come, he said, which will sound the third and call them to the fight.
Not perfectly, he said, what obstinacy. So he's talking about the fact that the Second World
War was very well planned. And this is 1923. When did it happen? 1939. He was planned absolutely
in detail. It's frightening. So he said, this is why my justice, unable to bear so much
obstinacy any longer forces me to withdraw from you in order to be free in its course.
And the pain you feel in your heart in addition to the pain of my privation, watch this now,
is nothing other than the pain of humanity separated from me. She doesn't realize she's
identified with the whole of humanity. And therefore, because she has possession of the
divine will, the divine will expresses itself in her and through her. Indeed, Jesus said,
it is a horrible pain, so much so that my heart writhed and agonized. And now, because
of the bonds that you have with me, that is she has possession of the divine will, you
remain bound to the whole human family as he is. And you are forced to feel this pain
in yourself. That is the pain of the human generations with their horrendous sins separating
from me. So we know that all generations are in Jesus, and then Louisa enters completely
into the divine will, the divine will in her makes her present to all the generations as
well. So he's saying to her, you actually can't escape this pain, because it's expressed
by the divine will inside of you. So courage, do not lose heart. Let me give free course
to justice. And then I will be with you again, and we will pray and cry together over the
lot of man that he may no longer go wandering on the earth, but return to his God. We're
going to do another little bit. Is that okay? Yeah. So September the 6th, 1923, I want you
to put a heading on this, the origin of sin. And Jesus gives the origin of sin as something
very, very interesting. He said, when you stop loving sin starts, because it's either
lover hate. So, and then he says, the reason why Adam sinned. Louisa said, I felt petrified
with pain because of the privation of my sweet Jesus. It seems to me that even his flashes,
his shadow keeps decreasing. My only support is his in his privation, which like drops
of Jew, sustained the poor plant of my soul, burned and withered by his privation, giving
it a thread so as not a letter to die. There's something missing there. She doesn't say what
it is that supports her. Okay. However, I was all resigned to his will. That's the important
thing. And I tried to do as much as I could to continue my interior acts as when I used
to take flight together with Jesus in his most holy will. Now, he's going to comment
on this that it's terribly important that even if you're feeling you can't pray and
you feel that everything is dryness for you, that it is extremely important to continue
the prayers, the acts. Oh, she said, but how differently I would do them, I would do them
badly, not finding anyone, everyone so as to give them my to my God. So in desolation,
she's saying it's harder to do what is easy to do in a time of consolation. Now, I was
saying this in my interior, my Jesus in your will, I love this because she's now doing
the act, I unite my thoughts to yours. And since your thoughts circulate in each created
intelligence, I want each thought to draw from yours the love of your intelligence is
not wonderful in order to place each thought of the creature in the flight of love. Now,
the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love. So the reordering is reordering
in love. Okay. So she says, this flight reaches up to heaven reaches up high into heaven before
the supreme majesty and blending with the eternal love draws the love of the most holy
Trinity upon the earth over all creatures. Now she's telling us how to do it. Isn't that
wonderful? So she said, while I was doing this and other things, because this is just
an example of what she was doing. My adorable Jesus moved in my interior and sighing, he
told me, my daughter, you cannot be without me. Remember, put your john 15 five beside
that without me, you can do nothing. Remember? Even less, he said, can I be without you?
That's fascinating. Because she's the only one on the earth who is in possession of the
divine will. That's why he said, I can't be without you. Everything you feel in your
heart is I, we would say is me. Okay, your yearnings, your size, the martyrdom you suffer
because you are without me. It's me time. It is my heart beats that reverberate in you
and bring you my pains and hide me from you. And this is why when love can endure no more
surpassing justice, it forces me to unveil myself. Notice surpassing justice, he's going
to explain to her in a minute where this justice comes in. And as he was saying this, he made
himself seen. My God, who can say how reborn I felt just the instant she sees him, it's
resurrection. And then he added my daughter, you gave me the dwelling within you on earth
and I keep you in heaven inside of my heart. There, that is the reality of truly living
in the divine will, you're living a life on earth, but you're also living the life in
heaven, you're living the life of the blessed. Isn't it wonderful? So while you are on earth,
you are also with me in heaven. So it's actually not possible to be without him no matter what
level of pain we have. The divinity delights with the little daughter of the Supreme will
having her in heaven with them as the Trinity. And since we have our little daughter in heaven
and on earth, see the benefit for the Lord, it's not worthwhile for us to destroy the earth
as justice would want to do. So he surpasses justice to go and show himself to her. And
he said, all creatures deserve that we destroy them. Isn't that something else? At most many
cities will disappear. And that's because of the intercession that Louisa is doing and
other victim souls as well. The earth will open chasms at several points, making places
and people disappear. Now, let me just point out to you, as of the 21st century, you do
know sinkholes are appearing all over the earth. And they are appearing in the most
extraordinary places. They're no longer appearing sort of out in open places, but in actual
built-up areas. One of the places very affected by sinkholes is Florida. People have been
literally sucked down into holes in their house, literally swallowed up by the earth
is quite incredible. The earth will open chasms at several points. Now, there are other kinds
of chasms opening in the earth in the 21st century as well. And that is that in, I can
name three places. One is in the east coast of Africa from, you know, you know, Africa
that goes out into the horn of Africa and then down towards the south. So you've got Kenya
there and whatever the other countries are. There is a chasm that has opened from approximately
Kenya down through almost the south of Africa. It has literally opened up like a huge river
wants to run through it. And it looks, the scientists are saying that if this continues,
there will be a new island, that part of Africa will be separated from the continent. The same
thing has happened in Saudi Arabia. And you really wouldn't expect it in Saudi Arabia
with all its sands. And yet it has happened there. And the third place that I know what
has happened is in Russia towards the east, towards Siberia. Huge chasms in the earth.
And nobody knows why and why they should happen now and why they should happen in a number
of places on the earth at the same time. I'm only naming three because I can only remember
those three. So he says the earth will open chasms at several points, making people and
places disappear. Wars will decimate the creatures, but out of regard for our little daughter,
we will not destroy the earth itself. Having given to her the task of making our will live
on the earth. Now what you're looking at there is the extraordinary power of someone living
in the divine will. Because of her, we won't destroy the earth. Is that extraordinary?
Therefore pluck up courage, do not lose heart too much during my absence. Know that I cannot
last too long without making myself seen. I myself can't do it, he said, because he has
to visit his home on earth, if the divine will is on earth. And you never cease to love
me, never, not only for yourself, but for all our dear brothers. I love that expression.
That's John 2017, our dear brothers. Because when Jesus rose from the dead, having the
apostles all having let him down and everything, he said, go and tell my brothers. That's John
2017. In fact, do you want to know why Adam sinned? I better stop, haven't I? Maybe we
should just leave it there and we take it up from there. You know this anyway. It's
your territory. So we stop there because the others.